Hello everyone! My name is Bruce Kerr-Peterson.
I am the head of the AdWords platform in Europe, the Middle East and Africa and Russia.
In fact, my team and I have worked with many people here.
But the collaborative project is through AdWords.
Get users and run engagement campaigns
All of this is related to paid advertising
I believe that everyone must be full of expectations.
Let me explain to you first, this lecture is not long.
I will talk about the following topics
Including how to maximize the product's appeal to users through different channels.
Retention rate and lifetime value
And data analysis and management
We have conducted a short survey of some users.
In the investigation, we asked these users
Which ads can drive them to download apps
As expected, 50% of users
Is because the search app is attracted to download the app.
Second is attracted by the middle two
Basically a campaign running through AdMob and mobile site channels
Display network
Finally, video ads served through channels like YouTube.
As we all know, video has always been a kind of
Campaigns that help increase brand awareness
We hope to change this in the future.
If it goes well
We will launch several new versions by the end of this year.
Let's cut into the topic below.
Ability to launch search ads on Play
We feel very happy
Although it was not long before it was launched, we have already seen fruitful results.
Not only increased user traffic but also reduced installation costs
User quality is even better
In addition, the campaign is fairly simple to set up.
You only need to enter the AdWords interface
Create a search campaign and set a few keywords
If you don't know which keywords to use
You can also use the keyword suggestion tool
Then run the Conversion Optimizer
Conversion Optimizer will choose for you
Target optimization per installation cost
Your ads will then show on both Google.com and Play Store.
Drive users to install products advertised in your ads
This campaign structure is very simple
The effect is very good
One of our main channels
Is getting users through AdMob and mobile websites.
We know that the effect of this method has been good
These two channels do bring
Very large user visits and extensive coverage
And the setup process is equally simple
Just upload a few text ads.
We recommend using video
Video interstitial ads have a much higher conversion rate
Target web random ads and take advantage of Conversion Optimizer
Find your ideal user for your target cost per install
Finally, YouTube
As I mentioned in the previous slides
YouTube has always been a channel that helps increase brand awareness.
But we also found
Users with high levels of engagement can bring amazing results
After we launch the Conversion Optimizer at the end of this year,
We should be able to be on YouTube
Adjust user acquisition methods based on target cost per install
To confirm that the user meets the eligibility criteria before the user downloads your app.
If you have to advertise on each channel separately
We recommend using this standard campaign structure and settings
In order to be able to maximize
Play the role of each channel
Our specific recommendation is, first of all, make sure that the measurement method is set up properly.
Whether measured by the AdWords SDK
Still measured by third-party tracking
Then start using the two main ad networks in our channel.
Which is the Display Network and the Search Network.
These two ad networks have been in the past few months
Very good performance
We firmly believe that their effect will be very good
So we recommend running both campaigns first.
You can add more keywords in the second week after getting initial results.
To optimize your search campaigns
When the two campaigns are ready and ready to serve
You can experiment with a YouTube campaign.
Try to gradually expand coverage
Use a similar list at the beginning
To make sure you don’t deviate from the original target
We know that traditional effect marketing
Focus on optimizing each channel separately
Ensure the best results for every channel
For some companies, this method is correct.
But for most other companies
It takes a lot of time and the execution is quite difficult
So the launch of the universal campaign
I feel very happy
And it will be fully launched today.
We will hold a press conference later this afternoon.
As Miles said, with this campaign
You can go through a simple campaign process
Target all of the different ad networks
This is the specific campaign process at a glance, very simple
Mainly divided into three steps
First, you need to upload a few lines of text.
There are some different changes in the text.
Then add the video and some images
You can enter your location, language, budget
And target per installation costs
Finally, you only need to enable this campaign.
Then the campaign can serve in all of Google’s channels.
And target app install inventory.
This is the actual display of the interface.
On the left side, you can see
4 different text versions
This conversion optimization tool can
Optimize and choose the best text version
You can enter a YouTube URL and the system will embed your YouTube video directly
On the right side, you can see
Google Play will automatically import
Your app icon and image
Therefore, it is obviously very important to optimize these contents.
When you enable these campaigns, it’s easy.
Because the system automatically optimizes your ads, bids
Banner assignments and targeting criteria
Our goal is to get the maximum installs at the target cost per install.
This feature shows excellent results from the beginning of the Beta test.
We are very happy to introduce this feature today.
In terms of user acquisition
This feature is expected to make you a lot easier
As I said before
It's all based on data and data analysis.
You can use some of the solutions provided by Google.
For example, integrate with the AdWords SDK to track and measure conversions.
Analyze data to measure an app activity
Or choose to work with a third party like many people here.
If you work with a third party, please let us know because we track the company with most third parties
Have a close relationship
Why do we have to measure it?
Of course because this is a paid advertisement
You must ensure your average life cycle value
Above average install cost
We know that there are 1/6 users.
Will not shop in the app
In addition, 80% of users after installing the app
Used only once
So you have to understand the lifecycle value of your app.
Then get users through the channel at a lower cost.
In this way, the profitability of the application can be achieved.
Life cycle value
Here is a very simple example
But from the perspective of advertising channels
We need to understand
What practical value can users bring to you?
Let's look at a basic case.
Take a user who has been using for more than one year as an example
We can see that a user will average on your app.
Spend $5 to buy goods
If you have a physical store
They may spend an extra five dollars a year.
Shopping at your physical store
And we know that these users will pass reviews, ratings, and messaging apps.
Promote your app to others
So word of mouth will bring sales increase
On average, a user will bring you $11 in revenue within a year.
Therefore, the cost of acquiring the user cannot exceed this amount.
Your return on investment will only show positive values.
In determining that we are willing to pay
After getting the cost of a user
We must understand how to maximize life cycle value
And enhance the product's appeal to users
Today the remote control does not seem to be very sensitive
We also surveyed another group of users.
To understand why these users like to use the app.
And what important business activities they will use for the app.
Everyone can see here, in the entire channel
Users like to use the app for a variety of different activities
Viewing other people's reviews
Until the channel terminal
Old customer feedback
If you communicate with users
And how to view analytical data, etc.
Understand what activities users have done within your app
Then you can create an interactive campaign.
Engage users in the most engaging events in the channel section
There are currently two ways to create an interactive campaign.
The easiest way to do this is to create a list automatically.
Just leave your Google Play account
Connect to your AdWords account
This way, you will see many lists that are automatically generated by the system.
Convenient for remarketing with specific information
If you want to judge whether your product is profitable
This is the easiest and easiest way to do it.
If you successfully complete this work
Then you can use the custom list.
You can import lists through Google Analytics or you can use lists from other servers or third-party integrations.
Create a list
And understand your users’ situation
The final step is to tailor the information to these users.
I have provided three examples of information tailored to the user.
If you want to engage users to interact with your app
First need to provide to all users
Content that can only be accessed or interacted with in the app
The second type of information is for
Abandon and stop users who use your app
You want to regain the hearts of these users
The best way is
Let users know that new features are available in your app
Use these features if they re-engage with your app
Finally, that is, what we usually see, users start to buy goods.
And added these items to the shopping cart but eventually gave up the shopping cart.
You can specifically target these users
Provide it
Only for discounts used on the day
To attract these users to complete the purchase process
You can see that we introduced two points today.
The first is to launch a search ad on Play, although it’s not long before it’s launched, but it’s very good.
In addition, we’re launching a generic campaign today.
This campaign is expected to streamline your user acquisition process
Make it easier for you
If you want to discuss this information with me, please let me know.
I am always waiting
Wish you be happy
thank you all!
[applause]
[play music]